[Music]
shout out to idk went to the idk
listening party oh yeah how was that
really interesting um
he booked like this small theater i
don't it was like at a restaurant
it was was crazy it's in hollywood um
it was like a 50-person theater just
above the restaurant
and i got there and i felt
everyone just felt really cool and i was
just like i don't
really fit in here and then uh
as i'm sitting there just like talking
with some people like around
uh you know everyone's got on like
really designer [ __ ]
like really cool clothes and
then this dude comes up the stairs in
this nwa hat
it's like kind of a huskier dude and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] is this oh that's mike
dean no way
no way i'm like that's mike dean that's
sick
if you don't know mike dean is he
produced for limp bizkit
you want to see the craziest wikipedia
[ __ ] of all wikipedia article of all
time
search mike dean on wikipedia
yeah oh you already had it damn that was
really fast
okay wait go down go to career and just
punch it up
oh no never mind i'm thinking the wrong
guy
who's the dude that went broke spent
like 70 million bucks not mike dean but
another white producer
hip hop guy what are you thinking about
scott storch scott storch that's
the craziest wikipedia search scott
storch on wikipedia
oh yeah mike dean is travis scott yeah
yeah yeah
sorry i'm stupid you're confusing your
white guys yeah
that's my bad yeah this is the wildest
picked up a cocaine by 2006 storch was
worth more than 70 million dollars but
also picked up a cocaine addiction the
year prior
in august 2008 he took a month off and
vacation in hollywood california
uh blah blah blah oh yeah this is
actually funny friend
and manager derek jackson said it was a
wonderful year
but i think it was defined by the magic
month of august he ran into the
hollywood class
and when he went to hollywood all things
changed he withdrew from producing and
focused on partying with friends at his
10 million
mansion in palm island florida he also
purchased a private jet
a 117 foot yacht and nearly 20 luxury
cars
about half of which he estimated that he
purchased while high on cocaine
storch squandered 30 million dollars in
less than six months
and was in dire financial straits by
january 2007.
yeah um a producer i used to repair
producers i used to
like intern for way back in the day
which in turn i used lightly
they used to work out of a studio that
scott was in
periodically and he's he was like dude
they swore that guy made so much money
under the table as well
he said rappers back then you know no
name rappers would just
show up with a literal bag of cash and
be like give me one beat right now and
he's like all right cool let me just
take it
no way that was like the you know studio
myth holy [ __ ] yeah
i can't very i mean how is that under
the table because it's like
circumventing the label and
it's like production dealing yeah it's
like not taxed it's just like some
you know yeah hands on a beat on a disc
like
um but yeah scott's torch so anyway
sorry you were sitting beside mike dean
well no so he comes with the stairs and
then him and
um idk uh we're just like talking i was
just like kind of standing off to the
side
um idk just knows i like like his music
so
it was kind of out of nowhere he just
texted me he was like yeah i want to
invite you to my listening party i was
like whoa what
so i bring this up because like that
i don't know man it's i've never been to
a listening party obviously
wow he's even wearing the nwa hat there
is it is it m my true
what mwa
that is not the nwa hat right that's
different
yeah it's mwa what is mwa
i'm gonna say mike with attitude i'm
like with attitude
oh man either way mike
with attitude mike with attitude
um so bro what's up
what what's up what's up man how are you
doing wouldn't you like to know
[Laughter]
sorry oh my god yeah mike with attitude
is that like his store nw i gotta piss
real fast cool yeah it looks like it's
his personal
birch line oh okay okay so yeah all
right so the hat
is a we got it here the hat was for a
label he was going to launch
okay either way see
you know um
idk text means like come to this thing
i'm like all right cool
whatever uh
i get there and then they open the doors
to this theater and a bunch of people go
inside
and then there are only three seats
available
in the front and i think most people
there you know i think there are like
some actors there i realized that after
the fact
like uh dude from the new girl
um lamorin what is his name uh
new girl casey
yeah with the cat oh oh yeah
um what's his name lamourne yeah yellow
more more [ __ ] hilarious yeah
he was there like some other people so
already like i feel like out of place of
[ __ ] i think other people did too
um it was star studded would you say
yeah more or less and like okay yeah
jeff was there he's in the back like
hell yeah
[Laughter]
and so everyone crowds around and then
mike dean's in the front and then
there's three empty seats and they're
only the only empty seats in the theater
and i'm just like
[ __ ] hell this woman next to me is
like are those open i go
i think so she's like i was like uh
that's like dean like i don't know if
he's saving it she's like i don't give a
[ __ ] she just says i don't give a [ __ ]
i was like well if you sit there i'll
grab a seat there because like i want to
sit she goes sure
so she grabs it so now it's me her and
then mike dean
um and then even after the listening
party ended i like
said to her i'm like you know you're
sitting next to mike dean right she's
like
who i was like oh damn really she wasn't
from america so
okay or she she lived in america for a
period but it wasn't where she was born
i was like you know
travis scott and she goes oh but still
wasn't i'm from holland
[Laughter]
so but the listening party was like
i've only been to like a couple art
shows and it definitely felt that way
like i don't know once it was the first
time in a while where you sat down and
like listened to an album straight and
it was good i mean
it's probably my favorite album to come
out in a long time that's not just
because i like his music
but um what was cool was
so he actually let me listen to half of
it like a few months ago okay
so he has a song with like mf doom yeah
final cut
only has mf doom for like a couple lines
but i like got to hear the whole verse
and
so i heard it without it and then i saw
him tweet like oh i cut it from the
album
just for whatever reasons and i was just
like
really wish i was listening harder
because like that's like one of doom's
like last verses like ever recorded why
wouldn't he keep it
i i forget his reasoning but that's what
i thought
but you know maybe they'll release it
later or something
but doom cleared that verse like a month
before he died
so it's like potentially one of the last
things he ever recorded
yeah it was just it was nuts but
when does it come out the album it's
already out okay uh let's call you see
for yourself it's got
crazy features on there uh j electronica
t-pain damn um yeah
uh it's like a whole range of [ __ ]
appearances on that [ __ ] so but like
listen that was a
so that's the first like listening party
i've been to and it's like a really
good sorry yeah i don't i don't mean to
interrupt i'm trying to get like a sense
of the vibe
you all just sit it was a theater it was
a theater yeah like a movie theater yeah
like a
song like a movie theater okay so
there's like a screen with like you'd
have like the title of the song
and the title would like sometimes
animate colors if i remember right
and then like the features would like
fade on the screen whenever
and everyone's just sitting there like
this they're just listening no so that
was the other part
well yeah yeah yeah or they're talking a
little bit
so they were talking in the beginning
but then so then
that was my observation the whole thing
is like bro this is [ __ ]
nerve-wracking like
you put because the album's super
personal and you're putting it in front
of all these people yeah i can't imagine
that
yeah and it's like people are talking to
the beginning i i
for me i was like damn dude but then
uh there's a specific song on there or
after a couple songs like everybody
settled i think everyone's talking too
because
it's just like awkward like for
strangers yeah they're people by
themselves being like hey
who are whatever um but yeah by the end
of it like the whole room is just like
like in unison just like listening i was
like this is crazy it's like the energy
was just
i've not experienced that in a long time
just because you know
from not going outside so like after i
did that [ __ ] i was like damn
outside is cool yeah that was like my
main takeaway outside
outside is cool it's good to be back
outside yeah so that's just a story from
outside everybody